scientists are embarking on a massive
effort to CT scan all vertebrates from
bats to Turtles to squirrels
countless animal specimens are preserved
and stored away in museum collections
making them difficult for scientists and
the public to access but the plan to
scan all vertebrates will change that by
creating 3d models of the animals and
uploading them to a free online database
over the next four years 16 universities
and museums across the United States
will scan more than 20,000 fluid
preserve animals covering about 15,000
different species even though there's
only 22% of the 68,000 vertebrate
species that will be carefully picked to
cover over 80% of living vertebrate
general to speed things up researchers
have made fish burritos where multiple
specimens such as these piranhas are
wrapped stacked and scanned together
this unique view of vertebrates has
already led to discoveries including new
species such as this clean fish that was
hiding in a museum for several years
they can also help scientists understand
new quirks about animal diets and
lifestyles such as this philippine flat
headed frog that ate a crab before being
preserved or this other frog that's so
tiny the ant inside its belly is almost
as big as its head Texas A&M will be in
charge of scanning anything large in the
past they've scanned an eel a bowhead
whale fetus and even a shark the project
will also pick about 1,000 specimens to
soak in an iodide dye which boosts the
contrast on soft tissues improving the
view of the muscles circulatory system
and brain scan all vertebrates is a
basic science initiative to inspire new
research and is a huge leap forward in
digitally preserving and sharing
biodiversity on earth
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you